I come to this video playing ha game
again from Spain one of the frequent
opponents oh I have asked oasiz to ten
wins one draw zero losses no no 10 wins
one loss 0 drawers okay so let's see
let's see what happens right now nothing
happens he very often likes to
fianchetto ace Queen Queen Queens Bishop
it's always playing one be three for
example no move and I can't let's drink
something okay let's see an English
opening let's let's play an open line Oh
get the maracas see bind now he's very
often fianchetto so I mean the Queens
Bishop so I'm surprised that we get the
more oxy yeah this is one of those lines
that I feel like I have played million
times it's a very common opening that
common opening your face when you play
93 and ce4 Quincy 7 is a strange move it
it runs into the sea file I mean it's a
typical opposition of the rook and the
Queen ok me I go to a 3 because I want
to prevent b5 at least I was able to
play this quickly simply because i have
had this position type so often in the
past
at some one of those positions that are
always like to play ed you know it does
not ed doesn't really fit with my moves
before yes this is this is what people
often play with be five but it's mostly
just weakening i get i get the night by
adi 4226 in the long run nights before i
take 94 c 6 coming and the light square
Bishop can be a piece that is really
missing now not sure b3 is most most
often it's useful
ook c7 I play night b4 you taking a six
check yeah the Sun this neat little
detail gave me the C file and tickle our
group c 8 because of 97 okay he might
try to move the upon what I can take it
it's not not a big deal I'm how to
continue not easy it's very comfortable
but how do we actually make substantial
progress Bishop deform we're sorry
bishop d 4g phone moves like that and
how can i enter on the C file maybe I
should try to prepare sefa play Quincy
one night a five this was this idea
okay night if firefox you want I can try
to enter them
not sure yeah it's a position where many
our many options are looking attractive
so not clear maybe you can go is six now
by going away from the default I maybe
have allowed you sick okay I can't I can
take though it's still good it's the
good de6 okay difficult for black to
move here the knight on c6 is not not
exactly great to face yeah drastic move
but I understand that that he wants to
do do something okay I take it and I
probably should take it at leave so many
weaknesses Knight f6 attacking here this
is of course this idea but I can just
take right and then push a queendom
Queen Queen F or something like that
attacking the week poll how to continue
though with g4 maybe he has he se 5
based on this somewhat unstable night
the night is now indeed unstable yeah
this is probably good getting it back if
he takes me out he probably must take
yes this is not not something that black
loves to play but it's probably the
relatively best option hmm the question
is should i take the smite might give
him counter flame queen takes and
queenie queenie one and gladys get some
counter play hmm i still have the C file
so nyah Queen edge for is not bad okay
very debatable debatable decision now
check Queen g7 I thought I can just take
what does he have is the chick Queen f5
Queen a one check king of two III check
mm-hmm yeah I'm not sure that I want
check I'm too slow for heaven's sake
what am i doing 30 seconds I mean the
position I spoiled but it doesn't really
matter ever lose on time anyway
Kingda form may be difficult time I get
caught up on time this is important and
to know am I not winning the spawn chat
him check hmm don't know somewhere i
have this guy's number no don't know why
fought my way back into this or he just
gave it away however you want to put it
can it has bought a very good position
before it was black farfetch honest it
was very nice and until this a 5v5 spot
maybe around maybe 94 it's not a good
decision I really don't know I really
don't know I hear ya maybe this is
mistimed I don't need to take
immediately there i am home as usual the
computer queen d to add this is stronger
it goes to d3 first yeah it goes to be
three first the point is if I if I'm
able to take on f6 and and prevent the e
porn from moving then it's it's it's
excellent just for example what the line
that it's giving just to show this and
now okay that's not the line the
computer is giving but rookie to wasn't
this good I can take the five I play six
crazy sometimes tactics out of the blue
night is lost at night before is the
comb move what about this this is also
better than than the game because it
cannot easily move the that you poor now
something like this solo lonely
improving this is just better time than
then the game rookie tours better maybe
I'm okay yeah and this always even got
the guy's got queen a seven I didn't see
that at all way it's not fatal but group
d 2 loops yet check and here maybe I
should take I was afraid that with this
counter play he he can exchange them
change too many pieces and draw I can
play this one yeah this is good though
really hmm gee coz this is just a bad
end game King here or group c 6 and this
was and then queen edge for wasn't
wasn't good check check my dear walk see
six is good okay yeah I wanted to get
the King into play maybe this leads to
two direct trauma hmm jam net DNT is
somehow spoil it yeah King the skin with
a stranger he just needs to stay active
rook f8 for example but with ruko f3 to
come hmm yeah bit of a lucky win at the
end but it was an interesting positional
game thanks for watching